before this happened I was having a
fantastic day two to three years ago I
was a college student I was on the
cross-country team I was a couple miles
away from home we were running along the
Esplanade which is this public park in
the middle of Boston and so it's really
pretty there's usually a ton of people
there it was probably around like 7:00
p.m. and I probably run about like 3 to
5 miles and I had just turned around to
start going back home and then all of a
sudden I'm just hit with the feeling of
oh my god I have to poop which happens
along when you're running it's pretty
common so I didn't freak out about it
because normally you can kind of like
just slow down a little bit or walk and
then I wasn't worried so I start walking
and the feeling actually ends up getting
worse so I'm like oh my god this is not
good
so I find any empty bench I can find I
sit down trying to like collect my
thoughts makes it so much worse right so
now I'm like oh my I'm gay it's
happening it's gonna happen so I'm
freaking out because not only am I in a
very public place there are no bathrooms
anywhere near me so I run over to the
creek and I like check my surroundings a
hundred times just to make sure that
nobody's around because I'm like I'm
gonna get arrested because I needed to
do this very normal human thing and I
pretty much get in the water without
getting in the water I'm like on a rock
so I just pull him down poop on a rock
by a creek in a very public park it was
the worst moment of my life and also
mind you I just run like 5 miles so I
was like drenched in sweat so it's
literally the most disgusting human
while this is happening
like I don't have toilet paper right I'm
not running with toilet paper away
luckily I had pulled my pants down but I
had to pull them back up and I'm sweaty
so they're like sticking to me and
whenever and I'm like I want to die it's
awful so I pull back up nobody was
around thankfully so I didn't get
arrested but I'm still at this park and
I still have to get home and now I have
poop in my pants so I had to walk
through the Boston Common at this point
in time I had just stopped working at
the equinox in the ritz-carlton so I
knew that you could go up and use their
bathroom and nobody would care Here I am
sweaty discussing poopy and I get
catcalled
I can't really remember what they said
but it was like three men and the cat
called me and I'm like you have no idea
it was also like a huge confidence boost
because I'm sweaty disgusting and I have
poop in my pants and I got cat called
but not really it wasn't it it was
amazing it was an incredible experience
I can't believe it happened I throw my
underwear out in the bathroom of the
ritz-carlton
got rid of all the evidence right
everything was was cleaned up the
private shame of it was a pretty
disgusting feeling so it's Christmas
time and I'm going home for about two
weeks so I was getting ready and I like
to take if I can help it a preflight poo
because the worst thing is having to
poop on an airplane and the flight is
about six hours I poop there that I
don't know why I didn't flush it
immediately
cuz normally I do but for some reason I
didn't maybe because I was getting in
the shower that would make sense anyway
I go home I'm home for two weeks I have
a great time I come back to my apartment
I walk in I'm just like I made with like
a sick smell it felt like maybe there
was like a vapor that it created in my
apartment and I feel like I walked into
it and I was like oh someone is cooking
something that has spoiled it's really
bad and then I walk into the bathroom
I'm like oh no it was me I've been
letting my human simmer for two full
weeks it took a really long time to get
that smell out sometimes like if I smell
something similar I go back to a really
bad place I don't think anyone should be
embarrassed about something that happens
to everyone we all have a terrible poop
story
[Music]
everybody poops it's not always gonna be
perfect it's more fun to laugh at it
that it is to keep it bottled up don't
keep pooping don't keep poop stories in
that's how you get sick
[Music]